nous puissions tenir les trois séquences
que la délégation enchaîne enchaîne ce
matin
mes chers collègues la délégation
sénatoriale aux outre-mer à engagé mardi
dernier ainsi que d'audition sur les
perspectives d'évolution
institutionnelle outre-mer je vous
rappelle que notre objectif est double
de faire part de d'abord un tour
d'horizon des souhaits d'évolution dans
les territoires ultramarins souhaits qui
se sont notamment exprimés dans l'appel
de Fort-de-France le 17 mai dernier et
d'autre part de mûrir la réflexion sur
une éventuelle révision des dispositions
constitutionnelles relatives aux
outre-mer à l'occasion de l'élaboration
du prochain cadre institutionnel de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie pour cette réflexion
nous bénéficions du rapport précurseur
du président Michel Magra publié en 2020
intitulé différenciation territoriale
outre-mer quel cadre pour le sur-mesure
que nous pourrons actualiser nous avons
également les terrasses des juristes de
l'ajdom
que nous avons rencontré le 29 juin
dernier pour notre second audition nous
accueillons ce matin en visioconférence
une des signataires de l'appel de
Fort-de-France madame miguelo présidente
du conseil régional de La Réunion madame
la Présidente nous vous remercions
chaleureusement de votre disponibilité
décalage horaire et de plus de 2h et
donc 11h chez vous je vais vous céder la
parole pour un exposé liminaire d'une
dizaine de minutes sachant qu'un
questionnaire vous a été adressé au
préalable pour préparer cette audition
nous souhaitons bien entendu vous
entendre sur la fameuse disposition de
l'article 73 alinéa 5 de la Constitution
dit à mon nom vira poulet avec notre
corps rapporteur Micheline Jacques nous
vous interrogerons ensuite et je ne
doute pas que mes collègues oront
également des questions à vous poser
voilà le Président vous avez la parole
merci
mesdames messieurs bonjour je vous
remercie de prendre le temps de
considérer
la position les positions la position de
la de la Région Réunion sur ce sujet
d'importance et l'avenir institutionnel
des Outre-mer nous sommes la région
d'outre-mer la plus importante sur le
plan démographique puisque nous comptons
800 presque 870 000 habitants
aujourd'hui et comme les
toutes les autres régions d'outre-mer
les difficultés sont intenses chez nous
puisque nous avons 40% de notre
population qui vit en dessous du seuil
de la pauvreté et donc
la Réunion est toute oui
si vous êtes toutes oui sur
l'avenir institutionnel des outre-mer et
à notre écoute vous nous avez fait
parvenir un certain nombre
de questions et nous tâcherons de
répondre avec
avec sincérité toutes les questions que
vous nous avez posées quand vous nous
parlez du bilan de l'organisation
institutionnelle de la réunion ce bilan
vous le savez c'est le bilan de 76 ans
de départementalisation
depuis la loi du 19 mars
1946 et c'est celui aussi des 40 ans de
la régionalisation
issue des lois de décentralisation et
c'est un bilan je pourrais dire que
c'est un bilan qui est extrêmement riche
et pour reprendre une formule un bilan
globalement positif mar évidemment par
des progrès évidents dans les domaines
de la santé de l'éducation de la
formation de l'élévation du niveau de
vie des infrastructures
désacquis sociaux mais un bilan
caractérisé aussi par un mal
développement traduit par un chômage
structurel la persistance
d'inégalités criante et une part
importante comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure qui de la population qui vit en
dessous du seuil de la pauvreté pourtant
nous avons à la Réunion une jeunesse
formée une jeunesse diplômée le
sentiment d'insatisfaction vous le savez
ce sentiment d'insatisfaction de la
population se lit très facilement lors
des élections par l'importance de
l'abstention et des votes qui sont des
votes contestataires si l'on considère
par exemple les résultats de la dernière
élection présidentielle il semble
manifeste
que les populations ne se reconnaissent
plus dans les décisions prises à
l'échelle nationale en ce sens dans
l'idée de lutter contre ce sentiment de
rejet des autorités publiques il semble
primordial de rendre effectivement les
dispositions permises par la loi 3DS à
savoir
d'impliquer
c'est pas facile d'impliquer plus
fortement encore les citoyens dans
l'action publique et de donner la
latitude nécessaire aux collectivités
sur l'ensemble de leur domaine de
compétences afin de conduire une action
publique qui correspond encore mieux aux
besoins de la population et du
territoire et ainsi la rendre plus
efficace c'est cela qui est important et
lorsque vous nous parlez de compétences
et d'adaptation des normes les exemples
de décalage
les aspirations et les besoins du
territoire d'une part et les limites
d'une des politiques menées d'autre part
sont manifestes et cela se voit ça se
remarque dans de nombreux secteurs je
citerai par exemple le sujet récurrent
nous avons vous avons là des collègues
des parlementaires les sénatrices qui
sont là le sujet récurrent les sénatrice
de la Réunion les sujets récurrents des
normes de construction qui sont
inadaptées au bâti tropical la loi
littorale
il s'applique sur les 19 communes de
Lille nous en avons 24 de communes alors
c'est 19 communes de Lille qui ont une
frange littorale le découpage historique
de La Réunion qui va du bac en des lames
au sommet des montagnes fait que les
services de l'État impliquent également
cette loi sur les parties du territoire
situé dans les hauts et donc c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas qui est
vraiment très compliqué toujours dans le
domaine de l'aménagement l'application
de l'article 42 de la loi élan impose
aux communes littorales d'identifier des
formes d'habitat existantes dans leur
document
d'urbanisme Scott et plus dans le cas où
ces espaces seraient classés en zone
urbaine la demande de la demande de la
DAL au niveau local il pourrait y avoir
des problèmes de compatibilité des plus
avec les scottes et surtout avoir avec
le schéma d'aménagement régional il n'y
a pas identifié ces zones urbaines des
dérogations vous avez ont été prévues
pour la Corse il dispose d'un pasduc
mais pas pour les schémas d'aménagement
régional l'application de la loi
résilience et climat notamment et on a
eu une grosse réunion
cette semaine sur le zéro
artificialisation des sols sous la pose
aussi problème sur un territoire
insulaire sur un sur un territoire qui
était truqué qui est limité ce concept
de 0 artificialisation nette aura
forcément du mal à trouver son
application sur des territoires ayant
encore à faire face à une forte
croissance démographique un fort qui a
besoin de développement et qui est
bloqué notre département qui est bloqué
entre montagne et océans et déjà c'est
un terr qui est fortement contraint par
des couches de protection multiple vous
savez nous avons un parc national nous
sommes classés au patrimoine mondial on
a la loi littérale on a la protection
évidemment la protection forte des
espaces agricoles et donc avec la vie
conforme du CD pénard des risques
naturels qui sont très prégnants un PPR
aussi qui gèle aussi beaucoup de
possibilités il est donc difficile de
compenser les besoins d'extension
l'insularité exacerbe la difficulté
posée par cette loi autre exemple dans
le domaine de la coopération régionale
et de l'action internationale ou l'état
ou l'Union européenne conclut des
accords avec nos pays les pays de notre
environnement
sans que nous nous y soyons associés nos
capacités juridiques d'agir dans ce
domaine ne sont pas à la hauteur de
l'ambition que nous portons d'une
véritable politique de co-développement
régional autre illustration
pour la région de pouvoir porter une
grande politique maritime et ça on le
dit tout le temps elle a la Réunion et
le navire amiral de la France dans
l'océan Indien nous avons 2 millions
200000 km² de zone économique exclusive
alors l'État exerce une compétence
exclusive sur les taf et que dans le
domaine de la pêche c'est l'Union
européenne il y a toutes les compétences
sur les eaux communautaires sans que la
région y soit associée voilà et donc ça
c'est
j'ai répondu là à deux questions que
vous que vous nous bousilliez
si vous voulez là-dessus que l'on
discute on peut le faire sinon je peux
continuer dans la question que vous nous
posiez aussi si nous souhaitons exercer
des compétences dans de nouveaux
domaines notamment des compétences
normatives
et vous nous demandez aussi s'il y a des
compétences que l'on souhaite restituer
à l'état compte tenu de la difficulté à
les exercer ou du manque d'intérêt que
nous pourrions avoir
vous savez dans tous les domaines que je
viens de citer il serait souhaitable que
la région puisse disposer de compétences
normatives je pourrais citer d'autres
exemples dans le domaine de l'économie
il serait également souhaitable que nous
puissions agir en matière de régulation
pour éviter par exemple des situations
de position dominante ou de monopole
ils sont caractéristiques comme vous le
savez les économies de comptoirs dans le
domaine de l'énergie la réunion ne
dispose pas de diagnostic de performance
énergétique comme cela est le cas en
France hexagonale vous savez les
classifications des logements de A à G
en fonction des performances
énergétiques et donc
et nous avions et nous avons aussi été
désignés comme porteuse associée pour
déployer le Service d'Accompagnement à
la rénovation énergétique à la Réunion
reprise sous la marque France rénove
dans ce cadre une méthodologie adaptée
au contexte local a été élaboré pour la
réunion afin de pouvoir réaliser des
diagnostics énergétiques des logements
qui permettraient d'identifier de
prioriser des travaux à réaliser pour
améliorer les performances énergétiques
il convient de donner la possibilité
pour la Région Réunion de valider un DPE
spécifique pour le territoire avec
l'appui des services centraux de l'État
cette demande est également relayée par
la Fédération réunionnaise bâtiment du
bâtiment travaux publics qui
conviendrait en août d'élargir le DPE de
la Réunion en incluant l'installation
des panneaux de
en autoconstruction et donc nous avons
donc tout ce travail à faire et dans le
même ordre d'idée on pourrait envisager
de modifier la RTA d'homme en prévoyant
pour les constructions neuves
l'obligation d'installer des panneaux PV
en autoconsommation en complément
d'échauffes au solaire et d'élargir le
champ d'application des bâtiments
tertiaires
et à contrario dans d'autres domaines
l'État
doit assumer pleinement ses compétences
c'est le cas en matière de continuité
territoriale l'État doit garantir
l'égalité de traitement entre ce qui a
été réalisé dans d'autres territoires
comme la Corse comme ça Pierre et
Miquelon et celui de la Réunion si cette
intervention de l'État est d'autant plus
légitime que la Région Réunion et la
région d'outre-mer la plus éloignée de
la France et de la France continentale
de la France hexagonale vous nous
demandez aussi l'appréciation que nous
portons sur la prise en compte des
spécificités et des souhaits des
Outre-mer lors de l'élaboration des lois
et décrets et la méthode qui permettrait
de l'améliorer
vous savez qu'il y a un réel décalage
entre la proclamation au plus haut
niveau de l'État du réflexe outre-mer et
de la réalité législative
pourquoi deux textes très récents et
d'une importance cruciale pour les
outre-mer mais qui ont fait l'impasse
l'un et l'autre sur nos territoires
malheureusement je veux parler d'une
part de la loi votée sur le pouvoir
d'achat et la vie chère et d'autre part
du projet de loi sur l'accélération des
énergies renouvelables déposées sur le
bureau du Sénat en septembre dernier et
qui lui non plus ne comprend aucune
disposition sur les outre-mer
quand des projets de loi sur la vie
chère et sur les énergies renouvelables
oublient les outre-mer on peut penser
que l'archipel France est encore une vue
de l'esprit dans les services centraux
chargés de rédiger les projets de loi et
les décrets comme si la nouvelle
architecture institutionnelle est
normative
issue de la révision constitutionnelle
de 2003
n'allez pas encore de soi et me basant
sur ma longue expérience de
parlementaire je peux affirmer que c'est
ce n'est qu'au prix d'une énergie
démesurée qu'on peut parfois rectifier
le tir avec des amendements
toujours au titre de mon expérience
parlementaire je dois dire à quel point
l'adaptation des normes nationales par
la voix des ordonnances et de moins en
moins acceptable et accepté j'insiste
pour que pour qu'il y ait une véritable
prise de conscience et qu'on réalise à
quel point le fait de ne pas prendre le
temps de réfléchir aux adaptations
normatives en amont entraîne ensuite et
parfois pour longtemps des conséquences
au détriment de nos territoires il y a
quelques pistes pour y remédier c'est
associé systématiquement le ministère
des Outre-mer mais associés davantage en
amont les exécutifs locaux à
l'élaboration des normes
systématiser l'application de l'article
73 en rendant obligatoire la
justification de l'absence d'adaptation
pour conclure sur ce point je dirais un
mot sur les lois d'orientation ou de
programmation relative aux outre-mer
elle doit prendre en compte la
reconnaissance véritable de notre
diversité ce qui implique de consacrer
des dispositions propres à chacun des
territoires bref de conjuguer également
au pluriel la fabrique de la loi pour
les outre-mer j'ouvre ici une parenthèse
pour préciser que c'est précisément
cette logique plurielle qui sous-tend
l’appel de Fort-de-France la refondation
que nous appelons de nos vœux
n'impliquent pas comme par le passé une
réponse unique mais doit au contraire se
traduire dans de multiples expressions
élaborées par chacun des territoires
alors vous vous dites aussi que la
Réunion est soumise au principe
d'identité législatives un passage au
principe de spécificité législatives qui
est-ce qui serait souhaitable dans
certains domaines si oui lesquels vous
avez la Réunion dispose d'un statut
d'identité législative renforcée
spécifique
article 73-5 qui lui écarte la faculté
d'exercer le pouvoir législatif sur
Habilitation du Parlement je dis bien
sur Habilitation du Parlement il
pourrait effectivement être intéressant
d'expérimenter le principe de spécialité
législatives à la Réunion dans certains
domaines comme par exemple celui de la
politique énergétique ou en matière
d'éducation et de lutte contre
l'illettrisme à partir du moment
ou cette expérimentation et encadrée par
une habilitation
et donc vous savez que vous me dites
aussi que la Région Réunion bien que la
Région Réunion ne puisse en faire usage
en application du 5e alinéaire de
l'article 73 de la Constitution qu'elle
appréciation nous portons sur les
mécanismes qui permettraient de
solliciter des habitations à adapter les
normes dans le domaine des compétences
de l'État est-ce qu'ils sont
fonctionnels voilà l'article 73 5 qui
occupe j'ai mes
parlementaires de la Réunion qui sont là
l'article 73 5 qui occupe le champ
politique réunionnais depuis 15 ans et
qui est devenu je vous le dis mesdames
Messieurs les parlementaires qui est
devenu à la fois l'objet de fantasme le
réceptacle de toutes les nostalgies mais
aussi l'instrument au service de
quelques arrière pensée électorales
ouvrir à la Réunion la faculté de
pouvoir dicter des normes comme cela est
reconnu à la Guyane à la Martinique et à
la Guadeloupe relève d'une approche
pragmatique parfaitement dans l'esprit
du principe de différenciation étendue
d'ailleurs au niveau national à mon avis
le sujet doit se concentrer plutôt
sur les moyens de rendre plus
opérationnel ce dispositif il faudra
bien finir par reconnaître que la
puissance qu'on prête à ce dispositif
dépasse et de loin sa véritable porter
et a totalement laissé de côté ces
imperfections qui ne sont pourtant pas
minces la lourdeur de la procédure le
coût élevé de l'ingénierie l'absence de
base de données listant les demandes
comme les habilitations sont bien
connues il y a aussi cette difficulté de
taille d'ordre financier puisque
contrairement à un transfert de
compétences l'habilitation ne
s'accompagne pas des ressources
financières que supposent sa mise en
oeuvre le fait que le nombre
d'habitations n'a cessé de se réduire
pour atteindre 0 depuis 2019 est une
évolution qui doit être interrogée le
projet de réforme constitutionnelle de
2018 avait prévu d'apporter des
améliorations pour corriger les lois
d'heures du
alors vous nous demandez aussi si la
réunion a eu recours aux Facultés de
l'adaptation des normes prévues par le
second alinéa de l'article 73 de la
Constitution ou des expérimentations
législatives le bilan que nous en tirons
là vous m'interrogez sur deux
dispositifs d'adaptation la spécifique
aux outre-mer l'autre de droit commun
comme l'ensemble des collectivités
relevant de l'article 73 de la
Constitution la Région Réunion dispose
en effet de la faculté d'adaptation des
lois et règlements dans les matières
relevant de ses compétences toutefois en
dépit de quelques annonces aucune
initiative en ce sens n'a été prise
c'est pourquoi nous pensons que les
marges de manœuvre offert par l'article
73 n'ont pas été épuisés et que nous
appelons à l'optimisation de l'ensemble
de ces potentialités pour des
adaptations normatives d'initiative
locale ou nationale
jusqu'ici aucune collectivité de la
réunion n'a eu recours au dispositif
d'expérimentation législatives prévues
par l'article 72 alinéa 4 de la
Constitution à vrai dire se donne les
guerres surprenantes dans ce dispositif
de droit commun était de manière
générale très peu utilisé dans sa
version initiale de 2003 du fait
notamment des conditions de sortie au
bout de cinq ans la suppression par la
loi 3DS de l'alternative généralisation
de l'expérimentation sinon abandon
devrait donner à cette possibilité
dérogatoire une certaine attractivité
même s'il faut le noter la pérennisation
de l'expérimentation déjà rendue
possible par le Conseil d'État lorsqu'il
s'agit d'une collectivité outre-mer
c'est l'arrêt 2019 relatif à la Guyane
il n'y a pas dynamiser le dispositif
pour la Région Réunion nous envisageons
de recourir à ce dispositif pour lutter
contre l'illettrisme qui persiste à un
niveau élevé à la Réunion
quant à l'organisation des institutions
les règles de fonctionnement de la
région à la Réunion vous demandez si
elles sont satisfaisantes si nous avons
relevé les points de blocage des
dysfonctionnements ou des problèmes
d'interprétation des textes
l'organisation des institutions dans une
région monodépartementale comme la
Réunion exige une concertation
permanente et elle existe entre
l'ensemble des acteurs pour éviter les
points de blocage ceci dépendent donc de
la qualité du dialogue entre les
collectivités entre elles et l'État la
conférence territoriale de l'action
publique est un bon outil nous allons la
réunir d'ailleurs dès le mois de
décembre de décembre et vous nous
demandez aussi la création d'une
collectivité unique de substitution à la
région ou au département est-ce que
est-ce que ça nous paraît de nature à
améliorer l'efficacité des politiques
publiques vous savez mesdames messieurs
la région mono départementale a fait et
fait toujours l'objet
mais force et de constater c'est très
important ce que je vous dis là car
l'épreuve des faits la Réunion est
parvenue à une répartition des
compétences cohérentes allons même
parfois au-delà de ce qui était prévu
par les textes grâce à un exercice
volontaire
d'harmonisation de compétences entre la
région et le département la loi neutre a
également contribué à une clarification
nécessaire des compétences respectives
de chacune des collectivités
certes des marges de progrès existent
mais la dynamique de développement
durable qui est partagée par tous ne
passe pas nécessairement par une
modification de l'architecture
institutionnelle je vous le dis écoutez
bien ça il est désormais acté que la
Région Réunion récupérera à compter de
janvier 2028 l'ensemble de la compétence
agricole qu'elle partage actuellement
avec la collectivité département cela
nous avons partagé cette décision ainsi
lui reviendra d'assurer la prenne la
pleine responsabilité en matière
économique permettez-moi d'ajouter ici
une réalité à laquelle on se réfère
guère quand on aborde les questions
institutionnelles à savoir la situation
sociale hors norme de la Réunion qu'une
collectivité comme le département soit
dédié aux social avec les moyens
d'intervention à la fois budgétaire et
humains que cela suppose correspond à
une réalité qui confère au département
sa légitimité
alors vous nous parlez aussi du rôle de
l'État comment nous jugeons le rôle et
l'accompagnement de l'État pour exercer
nos compétences si les transferts se
déroulent bien si un accompagnement
supplémentaire est nécessaire vous savez
à chaque transfert se pose la question
des moyens et notamment de leur
dynamique contenu de la progression
démographique et du rattrapage du retard
l'un des transferts importants en faveur
des régions d'outre-mer a été celui des
routes nationales en 2008 au moment de
ce transfert la région à l'époque avait
souligné que les routes n'étaient pas
aux normes de sécurité la route du
littoral la route du Cap là où c'est la
route nationale 5 la route de silaos
devrait devait être préalablement
sécurisé par l'État avant tout transfert
or le transfert s'est opéré sans que
cette mise au norme ni lieu la région
supporte aujourd'hui le poids de ce
transfert je peux vous assurer qu'il est
très très lourd sur les conditions de
mise en oeuvre de se transfert les
routes nationales et route à grande
circulation des problèmes persistent
l'état mélange un peu ses compétences le
droit de regard entre les circulations
sécuritaire routière Cannes la vie
négative du préfet sous l'ouverture
recycliste la nouvelle route du littoral
comme cela c'est fait lorsque l'on a
ouvert la première une portion de la
nouvelle route du littoral vous nous
demandez aussi si la décontract
déconcentration
si elle permet suffisamment à l'état
territorial d'adapter ses propres
politiques dans ces domaines de
compétences au contexte local
institutionnel juridique économique
sociale culturelle
moi je peux vous dire que ça c'est le
problème de l'État on l'a vu avec la
crise sanitaire l'intérêt de plus en
plus de déconcentration avec un rôle
accru des préfets qui ont adapté des
règles à la réalité locale alors vous
nous demandez aussi
notre avis sur une éventuelle fusion des
articles 73 et 74 de la Constitution qui
ouvre la voie des statuts sur mesure et
à la fin de la dichotomie historique
entre les hommes et Dom Dom comme quel
est le segardes fou qui devrait y
figurer compte tenu de notre vision de
l'avenir institutionnel de la Réunion il
va de soi mesdames Messieurs que le
statut à la carpe René au plus haut
niveau de l'État par Jacques Chirac en
2000 dans son discours de Madiana est
appelé à connaître de nouveaux
développements donc à s'approfondir il
est évident aussi que depuis la révision
de 2003 il n'y a plus de distinction
binaire entre les articles 73 et 74 dans
leur nouvelle rédaction respective il y
aurait donc une certaine logique à ce
que le droit
coïncide avec la réalité des
propositions pour un article
constitutionnel unique sont en
circulation nous savons mais il faut
être prudent sur cette question et
notamment cerner avec précision toutes
les conséquences d'une telle évolution
au niveau européen
je souhaite insister surtout sur le fait
que ce travail d'élaboration en quoi
doit sortir du Cénacle des spécialistes
et des politiques au s'élargir à
l'ensemble de la société il est
impératif et urgent d'associer les
citoyens ce qui suppose un effort de
pédagogie constant et intense cette
étape d'explication est nécessaire pour
écarter les postures démagogiques et
faire preuve justement de pédagogie et
vous nous demandez également
quel sens nous donnons aux notions de
différenciation et de responsabilisation
quel contenu concret on y attacherait où
on situerait la limite avec la lotion la
notion d'autonomie cette question est
importante car au-delà de l'aspect
purement sémantique elle permet de
clarifier les termes du débat la
différenciation
désigne la faculté de mettre en oeuvre
des politiques publiques à la diversité
des territoires elle est indifféremment
utilisée qu'il s'agisse de compétences
des compétences ou des normes or il
s'agit de deux dispositifs distincts qui
relèvent d'ailleurs de procédures
législatives différentes la
différenciation pourrait recouvrir la
possibilité pour une collectivité ou
plusieurs collectivités d'exercer des
compétences
dans ne dispose pas l'ensemble des
collectivités de la même catégorie
tandis que la responsabilisation désirez
la faculté pour une collectivité
d'adopter des normes adaptées à son
territoire
quant à leur limite par rapport à notion
d'autonomie dont il faut d'ailleurs
souligner la grande polysémie elle se
trouve avant tout selon moi dans
l'existence ou pas de l'habilitation
nécessaire à l'adaptation locale des
normes nationales ou à l'adoption de ces
normes de ses propres normes la
frontière entre ces notions c'est
l'habilitation
vous nous demandez si l'article 73 de la
Constitution devrait modifier quelle
disposition nous souhaiterions modifier
lesquels sont un point de blocage pour
les évolutions que nous souhaiterions
nous souhaitons nous souhaitons la
suppression de l'alinéa 5 de l'article
73 est entendu que des améliorations
doivent simultanément être apportés à la
procédure actuelle c'est ce que nous
souhaitons et donc voilà
j'ai fait un peu le tour de ce que vous
nous aviez demandé
parce que il est
devenu évident que produire l'avenir
d'un territoire et d'une société exige
de passer par la différenciation que
l'uniformité des règles présente plus de
risques que de solution
cette nécessité d'une différenciation au
sein de la République mais d'ailleurs
plus l'apanage les outre-mer et se
vérifie de plus en plus sur l'ensemble
du territoire national au point que le
droit commun lui-même est en train de
devenir un droit différencié cette
évolution rejoint en ce sens les propos
du général de Gaulle qui dès 1968 avait
affirmé que les formes multicellulaire
de centralisation qui fut longtemps
nécessaire à notre pays pour réaliser et
maintenir son unité son unité ne
s'impose plus
désormais au contraire ce sont des
activités régionales qui apparaissent
quand de sa puissance économique de
demain en effet pour revenir à l'article
73,5 notons que outre les possibilités
qu'elles ouvriraient cette suppression a
aussi une véritable portée symbolique
elle signifierait que les Réunionnais
ont confiance en eux-mêmes qui le
manifeste bref nous croyons dans notre
capacité collective d'agir pour les
intérêts propres de la Réunion et des
Réunionnais c'est finalement donner plus
de force à notre statut de département
et de région et vous nous demandez
également si la population adhère à la
perspective d'une évolution des à une
extension des compétences qui s'il y a
des souhaits d'évolution qui s'expriment
dans le débat public ce qui en est des
socioprofessionnels c'est une possible
révolution constitutionnelle suscite des
inquiétudes ou des espoirs moi je pense
que la population aspire à une plus
grande efficacité de l'action publique à
la réunion tous les acteurs conviennent
qu'il faut passer à une nouvelle étape
de notre développement compte tenu des
nouveaux défis autonomie énergétique
transition écologique sécurité
alimentaire insertion de notre
environnement géo-économique toutes les
objectifs sont partagés c'est de notre
projet de développement qu'il faut
discuter ceux qui veulent polémiquer sur
les questions
institutionnelles font diversion pour
notre part nous venons de lancer la
révision du Schéma Régional de
Développement économique d'innovation et
d'internationalisation pour définir ce
que l'on nous appelons la nouvelle pour
bâtir la réunion de 2030 ce sont les
exigences du développement qui
appelleront les moyens juridiques et
financiers nécessaires dans une approche
pragmatique et non l'inverse voilà
mesdames messieurs si vous avez des
questions je vais je vais vous tâcher de
vous répondre
merci madame la Présidente d'avoir été
aussi précise et d'avoir répondu de
manière exhaustive aux questions qui
vous ont adressées c'est fort fort
agréable de pouvoir disposer de cette de
cette vision y compris politique et
juridique sur les questions qui ont été
adressées moi j'ai une question sur un
aspect qui n'a pas évoqué peut-être
c'est justement lié à l'ancrage régional
de La Réunion est-ce que
il peut y avoir un sujet pour la région
de disposer de compétences diplomatiques
décentralisées ce qui n'est pas le cas
on sait que l'état de manière générale
n'est pas très
très favorable à ce que les compétences
décentralisées en matière diplomatique
soit dévoluer à des territoires puisque
il y a un aspect évidemment régalien de
relation avec les territoires étrangers
de proximité est-ce que c'est un aspect
qui pour vous mériterait d'être creusé
ou est-ce que la région aujourd'hui
dispose des moyens qui lui permettent de
développer des partenariats sur sur le
dans le bassin dans lequel vous évoluez
c'est une excellente question monsieur
et c'est vrai que c'est
compétences régaliennes mais
l'environnement
géoéconomique dans lequel nous sommes
mérite vraiment que l'on s'est interroge
nous sommes ici on le dit à chaque fois
notre la situation de la Réunion et de
la géographiquement elle est en Afrique
mais notre histoire c'est une histoire
française et nous avons autour de nous
des pays comme Madagascar plus grand que
la France une ancienne colonie française
27 millions d'habitants qui avec
lesquels avec ce pays avec lequel nous
avons une relation qui est une relation
constante continue étant donné que
beaucoup de Réunionnais descendent aussi
de
de malgache
nous avons cette zone économique
exclusive de 2 millions 200000 km²,
c'est la mer nous avons des pays avec
lesquels
la France a des relations nous aussi on
a des relations les les personnes qui
travaillent dans l'économie en des
relations c'est le Mozambique l'Afrique
du Sud et donc tous ces grands pays nous
avons aussi
ce travail à faire pour la souveraineté
alimentaire le circuit court et donc il
est évident que il faut que l'on
travaille aussi là dessus lorsque à la
Réunion on importe des produits qui
viennent du Brésil pour nourrir nos
bêtes et on était même pour se nourrir
soi-même et donc on a quand même des
relations à établir avec les pays de la
zone qui
permettrait aussi
dans ce on dit à chaque fois que l'océan
Indien c'est ce grand lac anglais il y a
le problème de la Francophonie nous
avons des 27 millions de malgaches qui
ont aussi
plutôt la tendance à apprendre le
français vous savez que dans notre
région il y a
cette
échanges que l'on peut que l'on pourrait
avoir avec toute cette région étant
donné que dans dans l'océan Indien vous
avez les grandes puissances qui sont
vous avez
la Chine l'Inde la Russie tout ce monde
là et la France aussi les Américains qui
qui se trouvent aussi dans cette région
et nous avons vraiment un rôle à jouer
et la Réunion est sur l'axe d'échanges
entre l'Afrique et l'Asie et ce qui est
en pleine émergence démographique et
économique on a c'est une question qu'il
faut que l'on creuse il est évident
comme en Guyane on doit aussi creuser la
question comme dans d'autres régions on
va aussi poser la claque le fait là
parce que dans le domaine de la
coopération régionale et de l'action
internationale où l'État ou l'Union
européenne on conclut des accords mais
sans nous et donc nos capacités
juridiques d'agir dans ce domaine ne
sont pas à la hauteur donc comme je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure de l'ambition
que nous portons
pour une véritable
politique au développement régional
merci Madame Présidente je me retourne
vers mes collègues peut-être ceux qui
souhaitent Micheline Jacques un corps à
porte
merci président madame la Présidente
chers collègues je vous remercie madame
la Présidente pour vos propos qui ont
été très éclairants j'aurai une question
les statues européens des Outre-mer
ayant été déconnectés de leur statut de
loi nationale avez-vous
identifié un risque en effet aujourd'hui
un territoire peut combiner les statues
de comme et de rupes et d'hommes et PTOM
restait rue pour encore être une comme
et un PTOM
tout à l'heure je vous l'ai dit madame
je vous l'ai dit je vous ai dit à tous
il faut être très prudent parce qu'on
est régions
ultra périphériques et donc c'est une
question quand on parle de l'article
la fusion de ces articles il faut être
extrêmement prudent en la matière parce
que nous sommes région
ultra périscope
ultra périphérique la réunion les comme
les aussi la Guyane comme les la
Guadeloupe la Martinique et donc
Mayotte donc c'est une question où il
nous faut avancer vraiment avec très
grande prudence madame
je vous remercie
Nassima peut-être je n'ai pas vraiment
de question je voulais remercier la
présidente de région parce qu'elle a je
crois répondu de manière très exhaustive
aux questions qui ont été posées par nos
rapporteurs que je remercie ici
et puis elle a été aussi très clair cela
peut pédagogie nécessaire pour ne pas
faire peur aux citoyens la volonté de
garder les deux collectivités à la
Réunion réponse très claire aussi de la
présidente j'avais juste peut-être une
une demande sur comme cela France
métropolitaine on parle sur la région
parisienne d'un grand choc de
décentralisation est-ce que un grand
choc de décentralisation est possible
pour le territoire de la de la Réunion
et peut-être que la conférence
territoriale qui se réunit envisage
aussi d'orienter des pistes vers une
plus forte décentralisation et c'est
vrai qu'au niveau des normes
principalement et sur celui de
l'autonomie énergétique il y a vraiment
pour les territoires ultramarins un vrai
sujet nous ne sommes pas pris en compte
même le débat qui a eu lieu hier ici
même au Sénat on l'a dit dans les
commissions alors que nous avons du
soleil chez nous et que le soleil reste
l'énergie la moins chère la moins chère
que ce soit sur le plan national on en
parle pas l'éolien en mer oui nous
sommes plutôt à côté de la plaque
concernant les énergies renouvelables
dans le grand débat national qui est en
train de se poser et la présidente l'a
bien souligné
en la matière c'est inscrit dans notre
projet de développement et
nous savons aussi que toutes les régions
de la France hexagonale aspirent aussi à
ce qu'il y ait une grande
décentralisation et nous rejoignons la
matière les aspirations aussi
des régions de France qui nous importent
nous c'est notre projet de développement
et même d'un art le dit bien parce que
nous avons tellement à faire sur notre
territoire en matière d'énergie et
surtout nous avons les moyens enfin les
moyens naturels puisque nous avons la
mer nous avons le soleil nous avons le
vent et donc
en la matière nous partageons les
aspirations des régions de France mais
ce qui importe vraiment c'est notre
projet de développement et la conférence
territoriale nous aidera mieux nous
parler à mieux nous concerter nous nous
parlons déjà pas mal d'ailleurs
parlons entre nous il y a vraiment entre
le département et la région nous
partageons
pas mal de
sujets
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure on a
le fait adhère que l'on va qui
la matière économique que nous allons
reprendre en 2028 et tout cela en bon
intelligence avec le contraste qu'on est
la seule région de France à ne pas gérer
ses fonds
européens et donc on le fait en bon
intelligence
peut-être pour compléter ma question
madame la Présidente c'est je quand je
parlais d'un grand choc c'est que la
réalité de notre budget outre-mer nous
nous
le validons sur à hauteur de 2 milliards
d'euros or sur l'ensemble de ce que les
outre-mer ont dans le budget national on
nous parle de 21 milliards est-ce que
sur ce fond là c'est le grand choc ça
serait vraiment de constater ces 21
milliards qui seraient avec en lien avec
les présidents de toutes les
collectivités de Rome comme la
possibilité d'avoir une vraie lisibilité
or nous ne l'avons pas quand nous sommes
des parlementaires nous votons le budget
de l'outre-mer à hauteur de 2 milliards
mais nous n'avons aucune vue sur les
questions essentielles que la présidente
vient de donner le logement
euh les normes de l'économie l'éducation
qui sont des sujets et même sur le plan
social la santé qui sont des sujets
cruciaux donc
c'était cette cohérence là que que moi
en tant que parlementaire je peux
voilà je je peux je dis je trouve que
c'est une négligence
sur le plan
national
à l'égard de l'ensemble des
parlementaires et des présidents de
collectivités des des drones comme
je vous remercie aussi pour vos propos
Minerve très
qui nous ont bien éclairé et surtout
votre volonté aussi également de garder
les compétences départements et régions
mais
à ma question en fait je voulais savoir
et je suis heureuse de l'apprendre
aujourd'hui que la conférence des
territoires se réunira le 2 décembre
parce que pour moi je pensais que
effectivement avant d'entamer un débat
institutionnel qui est toujours
passionné sur l'île de la Réunion et
même sur les autres départements
d'outre-mer d'ailleurs
je pensais qu'il fallait mieux que les
deux collectivités associées
effectivement aussi aux EPCI et au
mairies
harmonise leur compétences afin de
proposer des actions essentielles à
l'ambition de notre territoire et bon ce
apparemment cette conférence
se déroulera le 2 décembre et je voulais
savoir quels sont déjà quel serait la
trame
de cette conférence in
il y a déjà le schéma régional de
développement économique et quelque
chose qui va vous intéresser aussi la
gestion des déchets mais en même temps
nous voudrions faire aussi
l'ordre du jour avec avec tout le monde
parce que ça va concerner toute la
réunion nous voudrions faire il y a déjà
ça c'est deux points qui sont des deux
points d'importance pour toute la
Réunion et nous voudrions le compléter
évidemment avec tous les partenaires ici
on le fait pas tout seul et on veut
vraiment partager
les EPCI et les mairies seront comment
c'est déjà travailler avec le
département et la région à ce propos
il y a pas de souci
merci madame le Président et pour
éclairer le débat si je peux me
permettre justement d'animation si tu
peux éteindre ton micro merci vous dire
qu'à la suite de la réunion et du repas
qui a eu lieu à l'Élysée je crois qu'il
y a un certain nombre de courrier qui
vont être adressés aux exécutifs ils le
sont puisque j'ai eu connaissance au
moins de celui concernant mon territoire
et donc l'idée du gouvernement c'est de
d'avoir et donc ça va venir entre
guillemets
juste à poser ou superposer aux
initiatives de sur les différents
territoires et c'est pour ça que je
l'évoque quand même la présidente
puisque vous évoquez la conférence des
territoires à la Réunion le gouvernement
souhaite travailler sur neuf chantiers
je vais vous les donner dans l'ordre le
retard indéniable des investissements
les questions environnementales les
aides au développement économique dont
les territoires l'ensemble des
politiques de l'État passé au crible de
leur efficacité et de la création de
valeur l'inadaptation des normes
l'insertion des territoires dans leur
environnement régional la culture et la
mémoire la fiscalité et on résultante de
ces 8èmes les institutions Sisley
nécessaires c'est précisé dans le
courrier donc le gouvernement on fait et
ça a été servi d'ailleurs par
Jean-François caraco quand nous l'avions
nous l'avions auditionné donc voilà
voilà un peu le comment ça risque entre
guillemets de venir percuter
les différents travaux que les
territoires pourraient engager dans un
cadre dans le cas de la fonctionnement
normal vous voulez simplement vous
l'apporter mais je pense que tous les
tout est collectivités et notamment les
signataires de l'appel de Fort-de-France
vont être destinataire ou le son déjà
il y a neuf points mais ce qui manque il
manque un dixième point c'est l'énergie
à moins que ce soit
dans le point 2 questions
environnementales il manque l'énergie
quand même pour nous c'est une question
qui est une question d'importance comme
pour tout le monde je suppose oui je
suis assez d'accord je pense que c'est
certainement globalisé dans le volet
environnemental de manière de manière
sens commun
très bien
merci
il y a plus de questions
peut-être une intervention et ensuite
j'y vais avec Lopez
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
bonjour madame la Présidente et merci
pour les réponses que vous avez
apportées aux membres de la délégation
jusqu'à maintenant mais au cours de
votre intervention vous avez évoqué la
possibilité en 2028 de la région est
l'émission concernant l'agriculture
alors je crois que c'est bien ce qui a
été dit
c'est bien ça c'est bien ça d'accord
alors il se pose un problème je voudrais
savoir ce que vous en pensez concernant
les sociétés d'aménagement foncière les
affaires le transfert des d'une part le
transfert du foncier mais il y a des
gros problèmes sur nos différents
territoires y compris à la Réunion où il
y a la FNCF qui a organisé il y a deux
jours avec les différents représentants
des affaires de nos territoires
une rencontre le problème de la dotation
pour permettre aux aff déjà existé mais
de jouer pleinement le rôle et vous avez
évoqué au cours de votre intervention la
question de la souveraineté alimentaire
que vous envisagez évidemment ce qui est
tout à fait juste et honorable alors il
y a un lien évidemment sur le foncier
disponible et sur le la possibilité
également pour les jeunes parce que le
problème du chômage c'est vrai
pourrait être en partie résolu si
beaucoup de jeunes étaient
en capacité de travailler la terre pour
cette souveraineté que vous voulez il y
a l'autre problème c'est aussi le
problème des transports parce que vous
avez évoqué le développement économique
mais pour l'économie qui est liée
également aux problèmes hématiques liés
au transport et là sur votre territoire
comme sur les nôtres l'une nostra
interpelle et s'inquiète énormément
concernant l'offre assurancielle d'une
part mais aussi les complications qu'il
y a pour
transporteur et ceux de la réunion ne
sont pas à reste dans la mesure où avec
les différentes mesures qui seront
prises pour le climat et la nécessité de
d'avoir des véhicules propres et bien ça
va mettre en difficulté
en tout cas la plupart des transporteurs
lorsqu'il y aura évidemment des marchés
publics donc ce sont des éléments qui
contribuent à la fois au développement à
la réduction du chômage mais qui et qui
ont évidemment des possibilités pour de
d'emploi direct et même indirects mais
avec un certain nombre de points liés à
notre situation géographique et
particulièrement pour la Réunion donc je
voudrais savoir ce que vous entendez
mettre en place et la dernière chose
c'est la question de la cdp9 et la vie
conforme alors est-ce que vous avez déjà
prévu des actions à mettre en œuvre pour
changer les choses je vous remercie
madame je vous remercie vraiment pour
votre question parce que la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est quelque chose aussi
qui nous tient à cœur et j'ouvre une
parenthèse aussi pour vous dire que le
fait adhère qui est géré actuellement
par le dépendance et en accord avec eux
parce que c'est l'économie donc c'est
naturel que nous en 2028 parce que c'est
la seule région de France où le fait
Ader et géré par le Département donc il
est naturel que nous
et en accord tout ça en bonne
intelligence avec le département que
nous gérions le le fait d'ailleurs ce
que je voudrais vous dire Madame la
souveraineté alimentaire pour nous un
outil à cœur et nous tient à cœur parce
que déjà la Réunion on est
la région qui produit 70% des fruits et
légumes dont elle a besoin et c'est
remarquable je dirais même parce que
souvent on nous dit que la Réunion il
faut qu'elle soit meilleure et bien je
peux vous dire et ça toutes modestie
mise à part que
la Réunion la production locale
représente 60% du chiffre d'affaires de
l'agroalimentaire des outre-mer et donc
c'est une question d'importance et pour
avoir notre
souveraineté alimentaire il nous manque
mille hectares selon l'Association des
industriels de la Réunion 1000 hectares
et nous avons les terres qu'il faut mais
encore il faut vraiment défricher ces
terres pour que nous ayons l'autonomie
alimentaire et cela nous tient vraiment
à cœur et donc en matière de transport
nous-même nous allons l'année prochaine
mettre en œuvre les états généraux de la
mobilité et donc parce que nous avons
aujourd'hui comme sans doute dans
beaucoup des Outre-mer en Martinique en
Guadeloupe dans tous les cas chez nous
nous avons 450
000,000 voitures qui circulent nous
avons 28 mmriculation
tous les ans et donc c'est une nécessité
absolue pour que le transport en commun
deviennent disons populaires deviennent
un peu la règle mais ça n'est pas facile
parce que les gens sont attachés à leur
à la voiture individuelle il y a le
système du covoiturage mais c'est une
grande question nous en avons parlé hier
nous avons mis en tant que région de la
gratuité pour les
concernés par ce schéma d'aménagement
régional où nous allons vraiment sur un
territoire qui est
occupé à 42-43% par parc national la
forêt etc et ensuite nous avons 38000
hectares qui sont consacrés à
l'agriculture vous voyez que la
situation n'est pas simple mais et c'est
pour cela que
il faut parler plus par les mieux avec
les citoyens parce que on vit
aujourd'hui dans une société où il y a
beaucoup de fausses informations qui
circulent il faut le plus possible
associé les citoyens à la réalité
de des pays des
régions dans lesquelles nous vivons
souhaitez-vous poser une question non je
ne souhaite pas vous poser les questions
je souhaitais simplement madame la
Présidente vous saluer compte tenu que
nous avons partagé quelques jours en mer
avec les jeunes de La Réunion et de
Mayotte voilà et vous remercier encore
une fois pour toutes vos explications
claires et précises voilà madame la
Présidente merci
un moment magnifique madame vous vous
rappelez cela nous a rappelé et vraiment
que la France quelquefois
ignore combien elle est riche avec son
domaine maritime à l'oubli quelle est la
première puissance maritime européenne
la deuxième puissance maritime du monde
et donc que les outre-mer c'est la
richesse aussi de la France et pour cela
que nous souhaitons vraiment que
elle s'intéresse plus ça s'intéresse
mieux à nous qu'elle nous écoute plus
qu'elle nous écoute mieux
tout à fait
et bien écoutez si je si vous en êtes
d'accord peut-être victoire Durel
c'est monsieur le Président bonjour je
suis à collègue bonjour madame la
Présidente
j'aimerais faire une
comment dire un propos liminaire avant
peut-être de poser ou nous deux
questions Bello
nous avons un problème de méthode
en écoutant la lettre que les exécutifs
ont reçu que moi je n'ai pas
on nous propose donc de faire la revue
générale des politiques publiques
et donc
et
le problème déjà d'adaptation
ça peut être un problème de dérogation
où ça peut être un problème de fixation
des normes et quand je dis non pas
simplement technique ou de construction
des normes législatives des normes
juridiques
donc on va faire cette revue générale
par exemple et je prends ce que Huguette
Bellou nous a dit avec beaucoup de
précisions et d'excellence les normes de
construction
l'article 40 de la Loi Elan la loi
Littoral une certaine forme d'autonomie
sur la politique maritime une meilleure
organisation de la coopération
rénovation énergétique
sur notamment
sur les nouvelles normes techniques en
matière de rénovation thermique sur la
RTA Dom bon en Guadeloupe nous on a par
habilitation fait une RPG qui est une
réglementation spécifique à la
Guadeloupe qui a été d'ailleurs exporté
mais c'est vrai ça a coûté quelques
argent on peut y ajouter en matière
agricole ce que vient de dire Cotis
jasmin là ça faire la cdp9
les arts le transport bon on va donc
cette vision là et celle de l'État mais
c'est aussi celle de beaucoup d'élus de
dire que
il y a une révision constitutionnelle
mais en fait il faut d'abord améliorer
les politiques publiques dans le cadre
de l'identité législative et donc on n'a
pas besoin de bouger tout ça si on
améliore les politiques actuellement
conduites
j'entends ça depuis les vrais depuis
longtemps c'est une méthode et
quand on communique mal et ce qui
m'intéressait c'était précisément
l'opinion des politiques réunionnais et
l'écosystème réunionnais notamment
l'état de l'opinion publique réunionnais
c'est ton prêt oui ou non à faire un pas
et dans quel sens quel quantum quel
degré où on améliore l'existant
moi je ne vois un peu différente qui est
la troisième
qui consiste à dire on a fait
l'expérience en 2003 le référendum enfin
de consultation préalable pour
recueillir le consentement des
populations ça a été un homme massif en
Guadeloupe parce que on a fait des
erreurs considérables et on m'a accusé
d'avoir été en conservateur pour dire
non à l'Assemblée unique parce que ça
n'apportait rien dans le cadre du droit
commun je persiste à dire ça au point
que 10 ans ou 12 ans après je sais pas
combien de temps ce sont écoulés la
Martinique dit je la pratique je n'en
veux plus
la Guyane pratique je n'en veux plus
donc il me faut évoluer et évoluer à
plusieurs sens c'est soit on évolue dans
le cadre du droit commun en améliorant
l'existant par revu générale des
politiques publiques soit on change de
régime législatif
la troisième fois c'est le nom on fait
bouger la Constitution
très c'est une deuxième étape cette
affaire là c'est vrai que pour le moment
c'est la fête des élus d'abord des élus
les élus sont-ils prêts à participer aux
travaux de révision constitutionnelle et
c'est la question moi c'est comme ça que
je l'aborde en Guadeloupe j'entends les
journalistes demandés aux élus ah bon
vous êtes où l'évolution
sanitaire vous êtes pour changer le
régime législatif vous voulez une
assemblée unique dans le droit commun
vous voulez une assemblée commune qui
garde le département qui garde la région
mais qui aurait une seule comme Paris
d'ailleurs qui aurait une seule
assemblée gérant les deux collectivités
moi je n'en suis pas là
quand j'entends la présidente
[Musique]
ne dit qu'on peut faire mieux dans le
cadre existant on garde le département
on a se dit bah là en Guadeloupe de dire
moi maintenant peut manchot département
l'essentiel c'est la délégation des
compétences qu'on va faire et au
département si on garde les deux et à la
région ou si un assemblée une des que je
serai d'accord après consultation pour
fusionner
dans un cadre législatif assouplit
élargissant le champ des possibles c'est
ça la question véritable si on commence
à mêler l'état de l'opinion publique
l'état des positions des élus le
gouvernement fait exactement ce qu'il
est en train de nous faire pour dire et
bien mettez-vous d'accord sur les
politiques publiques est-ce que vous
demandez dans l'article 42 de la loi
Elan qu'est-ce que vous demandez après
la loi l'intimide sur la coopération
qu'est-ce que vous demandez en politique
maritime mettez de l'argent c'est la
meilleure manière d'enterrer le dossier
je le dis très clairement je dis qu'il
faut d'abord un consensus des élus sans
pour autant tenir éloigner les
populations parce qu'il faudra arriver
un moment après avoir acté des consensus
modifier la Constitution en élargissant
le champ des possibles avec le résultat
suivant c'est ce que nous disons c'est
ce que j'ai dit à de toutes les
autorités les éminences ministérielles
c'est de dire que si un département ça
peut être le cas de la Réunion ou de la
Guadeloupe
tu peux rester éternellement comme il
est c'est son choix on ne l'impose pas
de choisir en revanche la coquille
constitutionnelle qui va recueillir ces
demandes sera élargi assoupli plus de
choix plus de liberté pour choisir son
éventuel régime législative alors qui
est fusion du 73 jours 74 c'est on peut
voir on peut avoir aussi la frayeur de
Dieu mais notre argent sera séparé avec
les com donc il faudrait que le
gouvernement fasse un effort budgétaire
et financier je connais l'affaire bon
j'avais dit à François Hollande que
l'égalité transcende les statuts
j'estime que vous voulez devenir
wallisien ou un Saint-Pierre et à droite
exactement l'égalité française c'est à
vous à faire l'effort qui convient parce
que je veux méfie de la conception
française de l'autonomie qui consiste à
dire vous voulez plus responsable vous
voulez plus vous autogérer et bien vous
allez payer très bien il faut donc être
prudent à
mais moi je plaide auprès des élus pour
dire n'ayant pas peur d'être dans une
révision constitutionnelle ensuite
préparons-nous précisément après avoir
peut-être fait la revue de ces
politiques publiques pour convaincre nos
opinions que un changement qui nous
permet d'améliorer l'existence qui nous
permet en subsidiarité au sein de la
République française de mieux faire que
l'État central on ne prendrait dans une
loi organique que ce que nous ferions
mieux que l'État central le mieux placé
pour agir devrait pouvoir agir avec des
moyens appropriés et moi mon stade
aujourd'hui de communication c'est de
dire la population vous ne pouvez pas
arrêter monsieur Macron il doit
nécessairement changer la constitution
parce que il y a le titre 13 relatif à
la Nouvelle-Calédonie la Corse a demandé
à y être et quand on vient concrètement
maintenant pardonnez-moi d'être un peu
long la réunion de vous d'accord pour
supprimer l'alinéa 5 mélo êtes-vous prêt
à aller plus loin pour le moment non on
garde le département et la région et on
vient de dire que les routes par exemple
en 2028 seraient confiées à à la réunion
très bien ça devrait être acté dans une
cité AP ou puisque il y a apparemment il
y a pas de congrès à la Réunion donc ça
doit il y a deux instances pour faire ça
à droite constant c'est le congrès des
élus départementaux et régionaux et
maintenant il y a les maires après
l'amendement Théophile moi j'avais
demandé à mettre tous les élus
d'ailleurs pour d'autres motifs mais bon
il y a cet instant là qui est politique
et qui demande des compétences des
délégations ou des décentralisations des
transferts verticaux de l'État vers nous
et puis il y a la CTAP qui est qui
peut-être en matière horizontale donc on
répète le faire aussi aujourd'hui aucune
c’était à payer ça se réunit en
Guadeloupe aucune c'était napolé il a eu
le courage de dire vous les agglo il y
en a trop en Guadeloupe il y en a 6 ou
387000 habitants est-ce que on peut
gérer par exemple
le département gère les collèges et les
et les lycées par exemple où la région
et que tout ce qui est social c'est le
bon bref de faire une répartition plus
harmonieuse tout en gardant les deux si
on arrive à bien dessiner les blocs de
compétences pour le moment et je finis
la c'est bien un préalable je finis là
le gouvernement nous a fait le cours et
le Parlement nous a fait le même coup
quand je dis goût c'est pas péjoratif
croyez moi on a eu ici au Sénat une
proposition de loi fait par la majorité
sénatoriale les LR c'était porté par
Mathieu d'Arnaud il y avait un article 6
dans cette affaire pour dire on va
améliorer la rédaction de du 73 et voir
même de 74 l'article n'était pas
satisfaisant mais c'était déjà une
avancée par rapport à l'existant quel
est le problème de l'existant c'est la
notion d'adaptation et c'est surtout
l'interprétation du Conseil
constitutionnel qui est une
interprétation restrictive qu'en 82000
terrains a voulu supprimer les cantons
on lui a dit non c'est impossible alors
donc on a fait la révision de 2003 avec
habilitation moi j'ai fait 29 lois de
région j'ai fait autant de décrets de
région ça nous a coûté rien que pour la
réglementation thermique des
constructions nous l'avons pour la
formation nous avons un régime
spécifique par habilitation rien que
pour la rénovation ça m'a coûté 5
millions alors que cela maintenant peut
régler le problème avec transfert de
compétences dans les Bello l'a dit ce
n'est pas le cas lorsqu'il y a bizarre
ça donc ça a des limitations on a
amélioré quand même le régime c'était
pour deux ans maintenant c'est sur une
mandature le nouvel exécutif peut
reprendre etc mais c'est toujours
coûteux et ensuite vous n'avez pas
l'ingénierie technique et c'est vrai et
et souvent vous avez les directions la
ministre centrale qui vous disent mais
ce qu'on faisait pour rien avant
maintenant vous le fait mais vous payez
bon moi j'ai eu à vivre ça cette affaire
là donc c'est donc de savoir comment on
aborde la question politiquement avec le
gouvernement je sens le gouvernement
très frileux comptant sur nos divisions
comme c'est arrivé au Sénat et bien
lorsque l'article 6 des sont arrivés à
l'hémicycle on la retiré et moi j'ai dit
je soutiens ça c'est pas satisfaisant
mais il faut avancer après les
départements les collectivités seront
libres de choisir ou de ne pas choisir
de rester comme ils sont en plus il y a
notre verrou c'est que on aura une
consultation préalable des populations
et on aura une amélioration on sera au
moins déjà le contenu ou le vrai projet
de loi organique on pourra plus dire
comme j'ai entendu à Martinique et en
Guadeloupe on va acheter chatte en sac
c'est-à-dire aveugle tu sais pas mon
problème c'est ça si les élus
au point on nous en sommes et c'est
pourquoi la déclaration de Ford de
France elle est plus de 6000 que celle
de Basse-Terre fait il y a des années en
80 17 elle est plus timide on parle de
politique d'amélioration bien sûr il
faut améliorer les politiques publiques
mais si vous conditionnez une éventuelle
révision constitutionnelle à la revue
générale des politiques publiques un
conseil suspect à l'âme entre les élus
on nous fera le cours qu'on nous a fait
déjà au gouvernement le coup qu'on nous
fait aussi n'a de dire entendez-vous moi
on est venu me voir pour me dire à la
Polynésie n'est pas d'accord donc on
retire le texte on nous dit à demain ah
mais la réunion à un opposition vous la
Guadeloupe vous avez un autre position
on retire le texte moi je me bats pour
une révision constitutionnelle je veux
aller plus loin que la notion
d'adaptation je veux que nous ayons plus
de responsabilités mais sans diminuer
vous me direz que je demande tout et le
contraire de tout je veux que on
augmente les dotations octroyées aux
autres mecs compte tenu du long retard
qui le note depuis toujours et ça c'est
un combat ça demande un minimum d'unité
si on se déchire sur la révision
constitutionnelle en laissant des démago
faire croire c'est l'indépendance ou
l'antichambre de l'indépendance on ne
réussira rien et le gouvernement nous
renvira à nos divisions ou à nos peurs
moi je dis ça c'est pourquoi je suis
prudent sur la communication c'est
pourquoi la question que j'aurais posé
Huguette Bello quel est le débat public
à la Réunion quel est l'état de
l'opinion publique il y a-t-il monsieur
vira pour les continuer me dit-on à être
un missi dominici partout pour dire
qu'il faut garder l'article 5 et que
c'est une bande d'irresponsable qui
demande ça quel est l'état de l'opinion
publique parce que je suis aussi
conscient et je m'arrête là même si on
fait le découplage entre la partie
constitutionnelle travaux préalable de
révision constitutionnelle et la
réception par l'opinion publique il y
aura toujours un lien il y aura toujours
une démagogo dit vous voyez il prépare
des choses ils n'ont rien foutu en
Guadeloupe sur l'eau sur le transport
tous les déchets et que sais-je encore
sur la santé et vous voyez il demande
supplément de pouvoir messieurs
accomplissez mieux ce que vous avez déjà
alors il faut combattre et je vais
arrêter vraiment
personne n'a demandé des habitations
sauf la Guadeloupe et moi je l'ai fait à
l'époque personne ne demande
déshabilitations et j'avais même
aider la Martinique à avoir une
habilitation en matière de transport je
sais pas quel est l'effectivité la
déclinaison concrète de cette
habilitation si elle a été prise publiée
si elle a été utilisée on dit ça en
bouche mais on ne fait rien concrètement
pour faire les choses alors moi j'ai
résolu après 40 ans bon bref que 36 ans
de vie politique de dire
si je refuse un mauvais projet si on me
donne 2003 euros à votre compte parce
que ça c'est simplement la fusion dans
le même régime législatif qui est celui
de l'identité je refuse en revanche si
on m'ouvre le champ des possibles dans
la Constitution après on aura peut-être
10 ans 15 ans 20 ans de combat pour
convaincre nos opinions que c'est une
meilleure chose en subsidiarité et puis
ça change pas et et et a eu raison de
dire le truc des ruptes maintenant c'est
assoupli il y a je dis pas qu'il faut
pas être prudent mais c'est vrai c'est
Martin est dans le 74 et pourtant il
roule et a les mêmes
crédits que que d'autres rues
Saint-Barthélemy est PTOM et donc à
d'autres types de crédit peut-être
moindre mais d'autres types de crédit
moi j'appelle à la confiance et je
demanderai à mes collègues
entendons-nous pour dire oui nous
voulons travailler une révision
constitutionnelle pour autant ne nous
obligeait pas à braquer nos opinions
nous nous oblige pas à choisir contre
notre volonté un statut qui serait pas
adopté par nos populations voilà donc ce
prix à la blague que je
à faire pour que nous réunions
ce travail qui me paraît indispensable
et il y a une fenêtre qui est ouverte
monsieur le Président Artano monsieur
Macron n'a pas la majorité parlementaire
à lui seul on est en droit tenir compte
plus de de du Parlement quel que soit
nos couleurs politiques nous devons nous
entendre au moins à minima même si c'est
un mauvais projet mais qui améliore
l'existant qui nous fait sortir d'une
interprétation restrictive et et de la
du Conseil constitutionnel nous aurons
gagné au change et peut-être ce sont les
générations futures qui vont devoir
appliquer ça mais ne saisir cette chance
qui est peut-être unique pour changer
les choses chez nous sans pour autant
perturber le quotidien le nouveau
population
juste une proposition si avec l'accord
de l'ensemble de mes collègues avant que
ce rapport qui est un rapport très
important
ne sortent est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
réunir les deux commissions des deux
assemblées Commission des outre-mer pour
que on est sur la méthode une
proposition partagée et que notre
rapport ne fasse pas après voilà et écho
a d'autres façons de faire pour pour
clôturer ce que mon collègue a
brillamment résumé sur sur la méthode et
ne pas opposer de manière très clivante
un point de vue à un autre ça pourrait
être utilisé pour pour ou contre nos
populations
ça fait partie des sujets que j'évoquais
avec le président de la délégation de
l'Assemblée quand on se verra la semaine
prochaine pour être tout à fait honnête
donc madame la Présidente je vous laisse
la parole pour pouvoir répondre à
victorinurel
moi je pense que c'est les échanges qui
que nous avons ce matin
ça a été c'est vraiment utile pour pour
nous tous nous ce qu'on veut c'est
vraiment donner un maximum de force à la
région et répondre aussi à Victoria
Lurel pour lui dire que tout débat
serein sur les institutions à la Réunion
c'est impossible étant donné les
préoccupations et électoralistes qu'il y
a et donc moi notre horizon à nous c'est
pas un horizon électoraliste un horizon
demain 2023 à notre horizon c'est 2030
2040 c'est ça notre horizon et donc les
ce que nous disons si ce sont les les
exigences du développement qui
appelleront aussi les moyens juridiques
et financiers si nécessaire dans une
approche vraiment pragmatique et à
l'inverse dans cet esprit c'est le
principe de subsidiarité qu'il faut il
doit prévaloir c'est cela et donc
je veux pas de débat dogmatique mais
vraiment pragmatique c'est cela je pense
qu'il faut que ça qui doit l'emporter
je vous remercie madame la Présidente et
je vous propose mes chers collègues de
pouvoir mettre un terme à cette audition
merci chaleureusement au nom de
l'ensemble de la délégation de mes
collègues qui sont présents qui ont été
actifs lors de cette audition moi ma
présidente pour la qualité de nos
échanges évidemment la délégation et
preneur preneuse en l'occurrence des
supports que vous voudrez bien nous
faire parvenir notamment la réponse aux
questions que vous nous avez dévoilé
merci beaucoup et bonne fin de journée à
vous
au revoir